[Music]
one of my favorite quotes which I'm
using my writing comes from the former
publisher of the New York Times he said
I'd like to keep an open mind but not so
open that my brains fall out and that's
the key point
we can't keep we we have to scalp
skeptically assess the information we
receive we can't be gullible because
there when we get a lot of information
it's absolutely certain that some of
that information is wrong and so we have
to always filter what we get and we have
to ask ourselves the following question
how open does my brain apt to be to
accept that information does it have to
fall out and and by that I mean when
someone tells you something you have to
ask is this consistent with my
experience is it consistent with the
experience of other people around me and
if it isn't then probably there's a
there's a good reason to be skeptical
about it it's probably wrong if it makes
predictions that also appear to be in
disagreement with things that you
observe around you you should be you
should question it and so we should
never take anything on faith that's
really the mantra of science if you want
the faith is the enemy of science we
often talk about a lost loss of faith in
the world today I don't lose anything by
losing faith okay what you gain is
reality and so skepticism plays a key
role in science simply because we also
are hardwired to want to believe we're
hardwired to want to find reasons for
things in the ancient into the savanna
and Africa the trees could be rustling
and you could choose to say well there's
no reason for that or maybe it's due to
a lion and those individuals who thought
there might be no reason never live long
enough to survive to to procreate and so
it's not too surprising we want to find
explanations for everything and we
create them if we need to to satisfy
ourselves because we need to make sense
of the world around us and what we have
to understand is that what makes sense
to the universe is not the
same as what makes sense to us and we
can't impose our beliefs on the universe
and the way we get around that inherent
bias is by constantly questioning both
ourselves and all the information we
receive from others that's what we do in
science and it works beautifully in the
real world as well when you're presented
with questions or answers about any
problem there are a few questions you
can ask yourself that you should ask
yourself right away first of all you can
ask yourself do I like this answer and
if you do you should be suspicious
because you're much more likely to
accept something that appeals to you and
and whether it's right or not so you if
you inherently like something in some
sense that's a reason to be almost more
suspicious of it if you're a scientist
but then you can ask the question when
you're presented with information does
that information is that information
consistent with what I know already
based on data I've taken about the world
around me and that and by data it's not
just scientists if you if you're if you
put your if you're a child all children
do this you put your hand in a flame
okay
the second time you know not to because
you have the data that it hurt the first
time and if someone tells you you know
that flame isn't going to hurt you you
should you have the data to assess that
that's probably wrong so you want to ask
yourself does that information is that
information consistent with what I know
know to be true already and the other
thing to do especially if you get
information from a source you don't know
okay is to look at many different
sources and compare them and see if they
all agree if they all agree it doesn't
guarantee it's right but if there's vast
disagreement between the different
sources then it's highly likely likely
that you can at least rely on that
information be true it's the same way
science works science doesn't prove
what's absolutely true what it does is
prove what's absolutely false
what doesn't satisfy the test experiment
we throw out what remains may not be
true but we shrink it down as Sherlock
Holmes was saying what remains after all
that is done is likely to be true so
many sources question what you see and
whether it's consistent with what you
already know and be suspicious of your
own likes and dislikes when you accept
information that's probably the reason
we
shouldn't when we turn to the internet
go to echo chambers and just read the
sources that we like now having said
that if you look at many sources you can
also quickly decide which ones are not
reliable and throw them out if they're
not reliable in one case then you should
be highly suspicious of them in the
future
so we all turn to different sources that
we think are more or less reliable based
on our past experience try that and I
think it's one great way to filter out a
lot of the nonsense on the Internet when
I talk about being skeptical it is
important to recognize that you can be
surprised and something that you don't
think is sensible can end up being
sensible that's the way we learn things
in physics so when someone presents you
with an idea that may seem strange it's
reasonable to be skeptical of it but
it's worth pursuing long enough to see
if it makes if it might make sense and
to listen to arguments that might be
convincing that might cause you to
change your mind in fact there's a great
school of pedagogy that says the only
way we actually learn anything is by
confronting our own misconceptions so
once again while it's reasonable to be
skeptical of external information if
you're always skeptical of your response
to information then and what you what
your misconceptions are and what your
prejudices are then you will both guide
yourself not to accept nonsense but also
you will be willing to realize that
sometimes what you think is skepticism
is really myopia
[Music]